thanks so much Tina it's a real pleasure
and an honor to be back here at Stanford
full summer here in 1995 perhaps before
a number of you were born and I really
do consider sort of Stanford as as as a
my alma mater so thanks for having us
me I'm al that's Dave and the
good-looking ball guy here is
Christopher and he's the third partner
of play bigger and we are category
designers and we're going to talk a lot
about category design today as a
discipline but our hunch is is that in
this room today there's a number of
category designers many of uses
entrepreneurs probably category
designers you just don't know it just
yet and so we want to start with sort of
a simple thought which is that
essentially every product or company
that we really love exists because of
one thing and that one thing is a
legendary entrepreneur created a great
product a great company and a great
category all at the same time and we
call this the magic triangle it's this
thing that enduring companies really do
which is to have a product product
design capability and discipline a
company design piece and a categories
I'm piece they're the three pillars of
what we call enduring companies and many
of you are already studying a number of
these particular disciplines right now
especially in the computer science
faculty so agile development is very
much something that plays in the product
design side of the house growth hacking
is something that happens definitely on
the company design side in the sense of
sales and marketing distribution and so
you're already sort of learning
capabilities in those two buckets but
we're here to talk to you about the
third pillar of building an engineering
company which is called category design
and one of our favorite category
designers is a fella by the name of
Clarence Birdseye and Clarence was born
in the 20s in the United States and in
his earlier years he spent time up in
the northern states and he had this
observation which was the Eskimos would
fish that would bring the fish out of
the water drop it onto the
ice water bond flash freezes the the
fish and then they would take those fish
back to their homes and that would
consume those fish over a period of a
week a month or a year so long as the
state frozen when you defrost it if you
like that fish it was as fresh as it was
when it started so that was his insight
that was the thing that he kind of
figured out and of course in the 20s you
know there wasn't the plethora of
opportunity you have to have fresh foods
as we do today if you live near a farm
you probably went to a market and that
was cool you got fresh foods if you
didn't you probably ate canned foods and
so Clarence kind of railed this whole
point of view around fresh and he got
out and started to talk about the value
of fresh foods and if you think about it
that was the product side that was the
product design PC invented
flash-freezing it was related to
vegetables in that particular case and
he then had to convince all the trucking
companies in the United States that they
needed to take this frozen food from the
farms essentially to the to the
supermarkets and then he also had to
convince the supermarket's that they
should put freezers in and of course we
walk into the supermarkets today and
this is what we see this is called a
frozen food aisle in it you have frozen
vegetables which is what birds eye is
famous for but you've got pretty much
everything else and so he was a genius
at creating doing product design company
design and category design to the extent
that we all now experience it basically
a hundred years later and there's a
plethora of foods that are available and
if you look at your public can read the
numbers but I just tell you this is the
lifetime value of this category is
probably about a trillion dollars
already and so that when you become the
leader in a particular category you do
create a ton of value and so one of the
things that we did and when I say we it
was more me than than Dave was to really
and that's because I do math and Dave
doesn't do math he does the the genius
on the marketing side we did a bunch of
research here
around this whole notion of category
it's new and it's something that's
really topical at the moment and we
invested quite a lot of time and energy
and Clarence was one of the examples on
the qualitative side of the research we
interviewed more than a hundred of the
great leaders of technology companies in
the United States we did a whole bunch
of reviews around that which led to what
they is going to talk about in a little
bit which is what we call the category
design playbook which is how do you do
category design if it's a new discipline
what are the things that you need to do
to ultimately become what we call the
category King and then on the other side
we did a bunch of quantitative research
and this quantitative research looked at
every single company found that since
2000 us-based with VC backing and if you
do that you'll find that there's about
8,000 companies that fall into that
bucket of which about 850 plus or minus
are involved in an M&A transaction
that's their exit if you like that's the
way they create the value seventy-five
of them actually make it to being public
companies and so these are the two
aspects we want to talk to you today is
sort of some of our findings related to
this research and we want to start by
giving you a sort of what we would call
is the cliffnotes of category design and
there's five things we want to talk to
you about the first one is this is very
much the technology industry is very
much a winner-take-all industry and in
fact in our research which we did it was
called the time to market research is
available in play becomes less research
if you want to have a look at it it was
about 18 months ago that we first sort
of discovered this that if you take a
look at the market cap of the category
Kings relative to everybody else in that
field of 8,000 companies there are 35
category kings and they represent 76% of
the market cap of the tech space and if
you're the category king that is the one
that leads in the space you take seventy
six percent of the market cat of the
category think frozen foods lifetime
value 100 years it's not market share
market cap so 76 percent goes to the
winner and there's
in this particular research might be a
little difficult to see but there are
three cohorts three years as we call
them and it's pretty pretty much between
71 72 and 79 in the middle cohort
Facebook existed and so it distorts it a
little bit but 76 percent so remember
that the winner takes all at 76% the
second thing is is that we discovered
that categories themselves actually have
a natural life cycle and the natural
life cycle looks like this we call it
the category life cycle model and on the
x-axis the horizontal axis here you've
got time and what you're looking at in
that graphic there is about 15 years
plus or minus and I'll show you some a
little bit more detail on the timing
here but it's plus or minus 15 years and
on the y axis the vertical axis it's the
market cap of that entire category so I
think every single company in the CRM
category for example add up the market
caps of all of those companies that is
the category value and what happens is
categories in the first phase kind of
this is probably duh but it starts out
really slow and it takes a while for a
category to really pick up then in the
middle phase it accelerates really
quickly and then it'll drop off towards
that once the quatre it becomes really
mature nothing super exciting in that
graphic you've probably seen something
like that before in the form of a bell
curve but if you relate it over time it
looks like this the exciting thing was a
guy called Paul Gorski wrote a book and
he talks about the number of what he
calls providers explodes in the early
phase of a category and then ultimately
drops off over time and if you think
about what's happening here it makes
sense that the in the early stage lots
of competition not a lot of value in the
category itself in the middle phase
competitors are dropping off the
categories really taking off and in the
end phase one company takes 76 percent
of the market share that's what we call
the category life cycle model the third
thing we wanted to do was we looked at
those 75 companies that did go public
and we wanted to know was there
something related to age in those public
companies and it turns out that
companies that go public when there's
somewhere between six and ten years of
age are the ones that create all of the
value this is the cohort from 2000
onwards and we've looked back already
started to look back back through to the
the 80s and it seems to hold and Harvard
Business Review just ran a big study on
this actually based off of our research
that's in the latest version of the
Harvard Business Review and here's what
we found this is what we call a 6-10 law
and it is on the x-axis again you've got
the years and then we've been doll of
the companies in two years so all the
companies that for example a seven
created that amount of value in billions
and the way that we measured that was
the day after they went public we looked
at what their price was we looked at it
what it is today so the value created
since public offering is what you're
looking at and so you can see that
companies that go public too early
pretty much crater companies that go
public too late kind of Yanis right that
there's nothing really happening out
there but this mill SWAT this sweet spot
as we called it in the IP in the Harvard
Business Review is where all of the
action is and it started getting us to
think well okay so if age is the
determinant we also did something else
you'll see in a Harvard Business Review
which is we try to look at it but based
on the amount of money that a company
had raised and there is no correlation
so it's fascinating there's no
correlation as it relates to the amount
of money you raise as a company yet
there is a relation as it relates to age
and it started as thinking about well
what could possibly be driving that
phenomenon and it turns out that the
phenomenon is when you lay these two
charts over the top of each other what
you see is is that the middle section
this developed phase of the of the
category lifecycle curve is where all of
the value gets created and it makes
sense these are all of the actual
companies underneath that graphic that
you can see and it makes sense and
George Lee who's from Goldman Sachs sat
down with us one time took a look at
this for those of you don't know George
he's the head investment banker there so
he does this for a living and he said
that makes complete sense that makes
complete sense and the reason is because
you know public investors are looking
for two things they're looking for
growth and they're looking for margin
expansion or profitability
and if you think about it during that
middle phase what's happening companies
are growing really fast the categories
kind of exploding and what else is
happening number of competitors is
disappearing is dropping so pricing
pressure goes off you can then increase
your prices ultimately increase your
margins so that's why this is happening
and the final thing is on just on
category science is is that categories
aren't static they have these tend to
have these technology cliffs that that
that that they can for that companies
can fall off in this particular case
this this axes at the bottom is about 35
years that you're looking at its the CRM
category which stands for customer
relationship management it's a very well
known category in technology and the
winner the current king of the CRM
category is right Salesforce so but it
didn't start out like that it actually
started out as contact management you
folks weren't alive when this started
many of you weren't at least we used to
write paper cards they were called 500
factors I can see some of the folks in
the audience smiling already used to
take these paper cards and we'd write
your name and address on them and we put
them in a file there was a circular
filing when I wanted to call you I would
look up your name in the file I would
call you on a landline that's how it
went now I know that's ridiculous for
most of you in the room right now but
that's how it started and then when the
PC revolution came what happened was a
couple of Companies Act was one of them
and goldmine was the other assistly
automated your contacts I know this
doesn't sound dramatic for you folks in
the room because you do it every day
naturally on your iPhones but they
automated it you then took all your file
effects put it in your PC nowhere
contacts that was the contact management
category relatively small but it was the
start of this journey what then happened
was people said well gee if I've got my
contacts in the computer whenever I talk
to somebody why don't I just put notes
associated with that so they know what's
going on with my customers and
ultimately the Salesforce automation
phase of this story started develop and
then ultimately customer relationship
management
as a function cook that plus a number of
other things that you had to do with
your customer customer support field
support all of those sorts of things
bundled all together guy called Siebel
Tom Siebel put your hands up if you
heard Tom Siebels name all right so he
was the guy in the middle of this pot
and he drove this thing his problem was
anyone know what Tom's evils problem was
I'll tell you what his problem was they
had on-premise software it meant that
the installations took a long time and
were really hard to do and actually most
of them actually never even happened
so along comes this guy called Marc
Benioff and says well hey we're gonna do
all that in the cloud and he took he ate
their lunch completely and so CRM in the
cloud as we think of it today does not
have on Prem software and you may not
believe this but on Prem Prem software
was not even a term that anyone invented
you know who invented that Marc Benioff
why because that was the bad thing over
there called on Prem software cloud
software was the good thing and that
you'll find as part of the category
design things that Dave's going to be
talking about that's a lot of what
you've got to do you've got to position
yourself and of course we think there's
another era of innovation coming here
which we call mobile CRM and it's kind
of an irony also here in the history of
Microsoft and Apple if you think about
it in the early 90s and the late 80s
Gates was the greatest category designer
of all time he created this PC operating
system category blew up did an
incredible job with with the Wintel
consortium took over the world basically
and then he vented something called
front office there wasn't a front office
until he invented it and created a set
of software tools that you needed as a
person quote in the front office and
that was called Microsoft Office and
then if you've got a front office where
else have you got a back office and so
he created software for the back office
and this blue line represents the value
that investors had in the categories
that they developed Gates went away the
Microsoft went nine I along comes Apple
98 the quote second coming of jobs and
he introduces digital music completely
is that industry iPhones and iPads and
you know that story and again the yellow
line up here represents what's happened
with Apple stocks still so it shows you
that when you're a great category
designer when you build product company
and category together
you can create immense value and if
you're not creating these categories and
you're not in tune with how this plays
out over time you're going to end up
like the blue line okay so that's the
category science I'm going to quickly
take you through some brain science this
is really some really advanced stuff
that's been done in this part of the
world about why we make the decisions we
do when we're making purchase decisions
because in the end businesses ultimately
get driven by purchase decisions or
choices to use something in the case of
Facebook its usage and its first thing
is to know is is that you might think
this is not true but it is which is
companies don't live in space they don't
live over there or down the road they
actually live here in between your ears
they live in your mind and we've only
got certain capacity inside of this CPU
up here and so we need ways to organize
all of these companies and that's called
a container and that container is
actually a category and so you know my
friend rang me the other day and said
hey listen I know there's some snow
coming to Tahoe I'm flying in from
Australia I need to get from San
Francisco to Tahoe what should I do
my answer was go rent an SUV
what's an SUV it's a category right I
didn't tell him which particular type of
car I just gave him a bucket and said go
go get one of those go ask for one of
those and categories work because it's
kind of the way our brain works we'd
like to have a filing system we want to
put all of the different brands and and
products and companies into that filing
system and ultimately it's the way
people discover products and services is
via this concept of a category and
categories actually manifest everywhere
you just yeah you may not have thought
about it like this when you walk into a
supermarket that's what you see what is
the sign above the aisle
they're category definitions it's all of
the soaps detergents right so it's it's
a way of organizing and if you think for
one second that this is a random
assortment of products on shelves and
that the stores not organized for a
particular way you're crazy
the milks always at the back of these
places right why you've got to move gas
to all the other categories to get there
because they know that's one of the
things you're coming in so categories
have been an organizing principle time
immemorial and they also true in the
tech space this is a this is a famous
luma chart for big data landscape in
2015 it makes it makes my head hurt just
looking at it but what are those boxes
those boxes category someone has gone
through all of the companies in the big
data space and said hey that's one of
these companies that's one of those
companies and when people start to think
about well what do I need for my
business they start to think about okay
I need one of those boxes and then
they'll start to choose underneath that
they with the company and so let's talk
about what happens in our natural world
today we get more than 10,000 marketing
messages every single day we are swamped
with stuff coming at us and we're very
much in an over stimulated society right
now and so you can't make a decision
about any one of those boxes quickly you
just can't and so what happens is our
brain uses a shortcut system it starts
starts narrowing down and speeding up
the way in which we make these decisions
and the the the research here calls them
cognitive biases many of you have
probably already heard of them but it's
not about logic it's actually about
instincts and I want to talk to you
about three really important biases that
you should know as a category designer
and the first one is the anchoring
effect if I said to you hey listen you
want to buy my car and you said sure and
use and I said well it's $5,000 that's
an anchoring statement it's not 50 it's
not - it's five and now we're
negotiating on the margin that's what
great category designers do they get out
into the market they anchor the
conversation around what we call their
point of view right the world now comes
to
you it's a $5,000 thing it's not a 50 or
$1,000,000 thing the second thing is
groupthink you folks live in this world
every day when you turn on your social
machines what's happening you're getting
groupthink back to you if Dave likes a
certain beer or he likes a certain type
of snowboard
it's more than likely I'm gonna like
that snowboard will that be a two
because just because he's the buddy of
mine and I respect him and that's why
Facebook and advertising on Facebook is
going off the charts right is because
groupthink and the ability to influence
those people in your circle he's
actually more powerful than anything
else other than word of mouth in person
then the final thing is once you make a
decision to purchase something
it's called choice supportive bias once
I buy a particular brand I end up kind
of loving that brand forever and even
though it might not be better and
someone markets me a better feature I
don't care I'm in love with this thing
and so these things play a very
important role as you go to market and
category designers actually use these
brain shortcuts as part of the category
design process to lead people to
purchase decisions or usage so it turns
out if you go back to that slide which
had the 610 law it turns out that the
category growth actually is determined
by how fast our brains can change and if
you peel back underneath that 6-10 law
and you said hey what are the consumer
companies do compared to the enterprise
companies the answer is is the consumer
companies are all down the six year six
year end of the of the spectrum the
enterprise companies are the ten because
it's one thing to say hey would you like
to learn how to use Pinterest or
Facebook it's not a huge decision for
you it's an incredible capability it's
another thing if I'm the IT director of
Wells Fargo and you said hey I've got a
new computer you want to try it out to
run your system this takes longer and so
how quickly we can convince someone that
they should use this or buy that is
actually the determinant of how fast
these companies grow especially in this
uncertain world and in our belief that's
why conditioning the mind is actually
your number one priority as an
entrepreneur and as
CEO this is your job in addition to
product design
yep that's hard you got to get the
product market fit and there's a whole
bunch of techniques you using to do that
in addition to company design sales
distribution culture and all of the
other things that you need to build a
great company you also have to build a
great category because if you don't and
you're not the category King you'll be
fighting over the scraps you'll be
fighting over this the the twenty six
percent that's left for number two
through number ten so with that in mind
I'd like to invite my partner Dave up
who's going to start to talk to you
about conditioning the mind and the new
discipline of what we call category
design all right think so I'm Dave thank
you for having us today so al mentioned
we have done the research and we created
a playbook and I'd say we didn't really
create the playbook this playbook is
something that we have been researching
and studying through our 20-year careers
as operators as playbook merged from all
certainly all the research and hundreds
of companies we've spoke with for many
of the different things that were
working on and obviously all the clients
we've ever worked with and it was sort
of we thought it'd be fun today if we
could sort of unlock some of the secrets
that these category Kings were using to
become the kings of their category in
these enduring companies that we all
read about so one of the most common
things when you think about these
categories Kings and these the
development of categories we all enjoy
today is these designers take us on a
journey and one of the things that it's
kind of a trick I think most of the time
you don't hear about the king or the
leader of the category until it Springs
on you first time you see Pinterest it's
you know millions of people are using it
first time you hear about uber there's
ubermann a city so you kind of hear
about it late and you feel it late but
the reality these journeys are hard they
don't happen overnight there's teams of
people working very very hard to kind of
bring what they see in their heads into
and turn it into a great product and a
great company and one of the companies
that we did a lot of research on we
wanted to kind of unlock the the kings
you know what happened what's the story
behind the story and this is not our
graphic but it's a great thing you can
google that
B&B story here what happened and one of
the big Hoss for me and I didn't realize
this is did anybody know where the air
and air B&B came from yeah three of them
right and they rented them for 80 bucks
and what else where'd the breakfast come
from right and they advertised three
beds and breakfast for 80 bucks and
three people showed up and that insight
led to a very long path to what we now
consider a brand-new alternative in her
life that alternative is another thing
as L said another place to go another
choice when you go visit or actually now
when you go live in another city in
somebody else's home or somebody else's
room and that's air B&B and they created
this category of private hospitality
it started with three-hour air
mattresses long journey so what we
wanted to do is share a little bit about
that journey again we'll try to pull all
this into the next 20 minutes but
believe me if you're entrepreneur and
you ever walked down this path it could
take years in some cases to really see
the fruits of all this labor so when you
look at categories the one thing again
they all have income as they start with
an insight that aha moment and I'm
guessing many of you have already had
that aha moment and you're staying up
late at night or talking to your friends
or maybe not telling any of your friends
all right you don't want them to know in
that aha moment actually and americo are
our partner over at floodgate she calls
that the technology or market insight
and it starts there and once you have
that aha and you basically haven't slept
and you've been kind of using all your
classwork to fill in all blanks and how
to create a great company or a great
product one of the toughest things to do
is answer to one of the most simple
questions which is this insight I have
what problem does it solve and can I
explain this problem and have people
understand it like I was explaining it
to a five-year-old in this interesting
question we have seen companies and
worked with companies they've been
wrestling with this question for years
the problem with answering this question
is a whole bunch of other questions come
up if I'm have this insight is my
insight solving a problem that's an
existing problem with a really crappy
answer which is in this case if you
think about uber you know taxis could
get you from point A to point B but they
kind of smelled funny and they were
unreliable and unsafe or am i trying to
convince people of a brand new problem
they didn't even know they had
and I think air B&B is a good example I
don't think anybody thought there was a
crisis in the hospitality industry and
we needed to stay in somebody else's
home I don't think there's you know a
big big dilemma there but they convinced
us they conditioned us to understand
there's another alternative and the list
of problems go on and on and on and
these can keep entrepreneurs up at night
but understanding the problem is the
first step because as soon as you ask
what the problem is the second question
is what is your secret sauce for solving
that problem what is the answer and
again is it a market insight did
something happen
broadband back in the day opened up
social media and and and today
marketplaces can be literally invented
overnight connecting supply and demand
does something happen the market that
allowed you to take advantage and
capitalize and create a new company or
new product or again I said that tech
insight we did a lot of work with around
Diane Greene and what happened at VMware
and she's very humble she would say oh
we just accidentally created the whole
virtualization category I don't believe
that they're way too smart but there was
a technology there they didn't know
understand what problem it was solving
and so my guess is if you're in this
room there's a probably a lot of
plutonium creators a lot of answers a
lot of products get created without a
full understanding of where the problem
is there's old cliche technology looking
for a problem and the only I'd say this
if you don't remember anything else that
Al and I talked about and you're running
around with your new product you're you
do tech insight take one second slow
down and think about the problem you're
trying to
solved with that technology and believe
me people understand what you see a lot
better and I understand the value your
product if you just slow down and
understand that problem statement first
so we thought we'd have a little fun
again we do a lot of research and I'm
kind of a category geek so I'm always
thinking about whenever I see a company
I saw a new company today it was called
it was on demand gasoline what was it
called
fill it filler or something like that
and I was like is there yet filled is
there really a category where people
need gas delivered ie that's a that's
the first question I asked and what
problem is that I know I'm out of gas or
low on gas but how big could that
possibly be
but anyway every time I look at a
company I think about the problem
solving so here's a couple of well-known
insights well-known problems and they
were solved and the people who solved
them were also extremely well known they
built legendary enduring companies in
huge categories and you probably
recognize some of them louder guitar
that was Les Paul right
I want to surf in cold water longer that
was Jack O'Neill men in the wetsuit
which turned into a lifestyle brand I
already talked about stinky taxis the
bottom one though here this one is this
one's sort of emerged it was right in
front of my face every time I went
shopping and kind of was driving in my
car and I didn't even realize it was a
problem being solved which is just
because I'm tired doesn't mean I'm
thirsty anybody have a guess what
company's behind that 5-hour energy just
because I'm tired doesn't mean I'm
thirsty and if you read the story about
how 5-hour energy emerged it was pretty
classic I'm tired I don't want to drink
coffee I don't want to drink a giant can
of yuck right
Red Bull or nitrous powered Gatorade or
any of that crap that you know you don't
even know what you're drinking or in
fact I don't know what's in this 5-hour
energy either actually I had one right
before I stepped up here so that's that
explains a lot but it's a pretty amazing
product insight but it also led to a new
category and how do you know it's a new
category one
of the tells is it's not stock next to
energy drinks it's called the energy
shot and they put it at point of sale
right before you leave Safeway and they
put it right next to the cigarettes and
gas stations it's a new category does it
live next to energy drinks at coca-cola
and coffee a lot of a lot of insights
there I hope those questions maybe help
you see the world through a different
lens but once you understand the problem
in your answer or you got to think of
your name right and one of our favorite
questions asked is if you solve the
problem that's been keeping you up at
night perfectly what category are you in
you know are you a C Panda
are you a killer whale I would rather be
a killer whale but if you think about
category names
I think category naming has got a bad
name a lot of three-letter acronyms
right and about sections inside of press
releases nobody even knows where they
come from random BS generators all that
kind of stuff but there is a science and
a psychology behind this name I'll
mention the name of the game as this
cognitive bias how can you create a new
space a new drawer in the kitchen a new
a new file in the file server in your
head to go to to understand the value or
what problem I'm solving with a
particular product that's what this
category naming world does it gives you
a new place an energy shot there's a lot
of intuitive work going around the name
and why it's important and it needs to
be functionally intuitive for users so
they know exactly how often they're
gonna use your product every day it has
to be functionally intuitive for
budgeting for CFOs if it looks like
something that lives in a budget that's
a good thing if you're specially in the
b2b space but naming is a lot of art and
a lot of science and I'll mention
earlier on the CRM curves these
evolutions and Marc Benioff is a master
he truly was and I was around I'm gonna
date myself to when Marc Benioff and
Salesforce came out and started talking
about something called an ASP and I
remember I was working at mercury
Interactive and we were making a
lotta money testing failed Siebel
implementations that was our business it
was great
Siebel sevens coming you're gonna buy a
lot of mercury because you had to test
that stuff and it didn't really work
that well and Mark came out and he
didn't say I have a better Salesforce
automation tool than Tom Siebel and if
we have seen CRM as sort of like a
funnel and a database right there's not
a lot of depth in it instead he said I
have something new it's called an
application service provider ASP didn't
even say cloud it was a new delivery
mechanism for software and then he also
had to do the hard talk about Clarence
Birdseye he was out there convincing
Wall Street about something called
software as-a-service people are gonna
buy software differently before you had
to buy software in a perpetual license
or a perpetual license of Siebel could
cost you twenty five million dollars up
front US cash where Marc Benioff came
out with salesforce.com and it was
almost coin-operated put some money in
and out comes your CRM so think about
that he went from ASP a new delivery
category SAS a new model a new revenue
model and then ultimately that led to
the cloud it will talk more about what
Mark did to really really stick it to
all the folks in this world called
on-premise which he did invent that term
and was not called on-premise before
Benioff came out and started sharing
with the world a new alternative to
software and you can't talk about
category design without mentioning Steve
Jobs and again if you remember Alice
chart we saw what happened when
Microsoft took their foot off the pedal
and what happened when Steve came back
to work in one of the great case studies
we admire is what happened when Apple
and in particular Steve Jobs launched
the iPad and I don't know if you
remember do remember when Microsoft had
that PC tablet thing didn't work that
well Newton's early right they were a
lot of failed attempts at this kind of
thing in between a phone and a computer
but when Steve Jobs launched the iPad I
stood on stage and he said there's a new
category a new place something that's
not a phone
and something that's not a computer and
it needs to be in your life creates more
engagement than your Mac at your
computer and it does a lot it has a lot
more horsepower than your phone he put
that in our heads and made it okay to
buy four or five billion dollars where
that stuff right it was not a
coincidence he didn't say I got a brand
new device and it's so much better than
anything you've seen before so you got
your name you got your problem you got
your plutonium now how do you share with
the world
who else is participating in your
category one of the most common
questions we hear is there ever such
thing as a category of one doesn't exist
because there's always an ecosystem
there's always a supply chain there's
always people processes and technologies
required beyond your capabilities in
your own company to fulfill the category
promise to solve the problem no one
company can solve that problem and so a
blueprint and ecosystem as a as a way
culture mall map it tells you everything
inside the category you need to solve
and where we fit within that answer and
one of the best examples of this was
what happened I think it was last month
at f8 where Mark Zuckerberg released the
new ecosystem and blueprint for Facebook
in the world of social media and
communications and what this blueprint
does is the psychological it has a huge
psychological impact there were elements
and all those biases anchoring effect
this is the new world right and he led
us inside his head we didn't have to
guess where we're going anymore he said
this is exactly where we're going we're
here now there's a whole bunch of new
stuff in Facebook that you're gonna
enjoy five years from now you're gonna
see enhancements to all the stuff you're
already enjoying today through video and
messaging and in the future reach under
your chairs and you're going to find
your new virtual reality set we're gonna
live in a virtual world
augmented reality he shared the world
his us his vision his category and now
he's gonna Shepherd us along and the
feeling you have when you see this is
enlistment and that's what category
designers do they enlist you in a cause
so every category had designer that's
specifically the category Kings that we
know and those entrepreneurs are kind of
you know locked in our minds has a point
of view and a point of view is often
mistaken for messaging or marketing or
even positioning and it's all of those
but it's more and it's bigger than that
a point of view establishes what you
stand for and establishes what you stand
against it attracts the people you want
to attract into your business into your
ecosystem into your category and it
repels the people you don't want to do
business with and the point of view is
built around a framework that's been
around for a long long time framing the
problem painting clear ramifications for
not solving that problem sharing the
vision for the future and outlining the
business outcomes and what to do now so
as anybody ever stayed up late and seen
an infomercial like the Zumba that you
know that thing that crawls around on
your floor and sweeps up everything have
you ever knows how infomercials start
black and white right it's always the
problem they frame the problem upfront
and then it turns to vibrant colors the
vision for the future and then operators
are standing by this framework is also
and I would say it used to be used in
politics now they does yell at each
other but it used to be used really well
in politics and I admired it and we've
all experienced people could truly frame
problems and own the agenda and many of
you may be studying this too if you're
working in the world of debate there's
this all you have to do is google
agenda-setting theory and there's this
whole notion of how you can get into the
brain by framing the problem in such a
way that you must have the answer so the
point of view starts with that story but
that's not the whole story I guess
around a point of view it's just one
piece of it the second piece is a point
of view has to make you feel a certain
way there's a famous saying nobody will
ever remember what you say but they'll
always remember how you feel
so we'd recognize these logos one
Southwest Airlines the others United so
raise your hand if you think Southwest
Airlines has a point of view a lot of
hands are up so how do you know because
you feel it they like you okay they
don't hate you for flying with them all
right you can do things like change your
flight or maybe take a bag with you and
not get charged right they smile you can
feel welcome in their in their in their
category and in their in their brand
they have a point of view and you could
argue whether the flights are a little
bit cheaper right that's the better
worse they're not gonna get you there
any faster but that's why they have
unfair competitive advantage over
companies like United they have a point
of view it makes you feel a certain way
Apple versus Microsoft same thing right
I was in the Apple Store on a Monday at
two o'clock in the afternoon there's
still a big lineup to the Genius Bar and
people look like they're having a good
time standing in line in an Apple store
and then you it was I think it was in
the in the Stanford mall and then you
look across right across there's that
empty Microsoft Store all those guys
weren't t-shirts kind of wondering what
happened it's different point of view
versus better products there's also
characters right Larry Ellison you can
have your own opinions but everybody
knows Larry Ellison he was an Oprah
Winfrey there's a book written about
Larry Ellison said that that the title
of the book was the difference between
God and Larry Ellison God doesn't think
he's Larry Ellison
that's a famous category designer right
there right Marc Benioff when he started
he was nuts he was hanging around with
the Dalai Lama everybody thought he was
nuts there's no way you can have a no
software software agenda impossible but
yet now he's a philanthropic leader of
visionary he brings a lot of good to
this world so these characters are part
of the point of view too and when you
think about these companies this big
idea you have these tech insights think
about the whole story that
be told about you because this is where
I'll mention these companies and
categories live inside your head create
create a story stick in that head right
creat the you know your co-founders your
founders the cumple we admire they're
all part of the same act and of course
we mentioned this before but the
ultimate point of view that we admire
the most is the no software software
agenda that Marc Benioff launched it's
absurd to think that you can have tell
the world no software when you are
software company it's kind of hard to
compete with especially if you're on
unpress promise software so the last
piece we want to talk about is this
notion of a lightning strike how do you
know you're involved or on the back end
or in the targets of a category designer
you're gonna feel it they hit the world
with something called a lightning strike
and these lightning strikes are
purposely built to move the mind to
condition the mind to set the anchors to
convince you that the purchase you made
it was a great position to convince you
that there's a king and you need a run
towards that King and and follow all the
follow the crowd it's on purpose they
target you they hit you and they
influence every influencer around you
and every time you see a TechCrunch
article or every time you read a big
profile and Fortune magazine or you
start to hear about the big buzz around
these companies I don't know if they're
all doing it on purpose but there is a
fair number of these category designers
are out there purposely targeting you to
make you excited about their point of
view their story their their products
their tech insights this is a little bit
inside baseball but I would say once you
get into these bigger companies or even
a small startup that starts to grow what
happens is companies start to form silos
these functional silos sales marketing
products channels they operate
independently of each other we've all
worked with those companies where the
salesperson is selling something the
marketing teams are marketing something
and the CEO saying something completely
different on the earnings call well
lightning strikes are used by category
designers to line the company for one in
one campaign one in one point of view
one visionary statement
and we see it all the time you just
might not realize these are lightning
strikes and they are docker con if
you're in the app world you know docker
Khan they're pulling everybody in there
enlisting people to join their cause
it's almost religious does anybody but
went to one of their events it's quite a
it's quite a performance they put on a
lot of respect for these guys
virtual reality you know I think Mark
Zuckerberg did his best Oprah Winfrey
and handed out the the VR kits and
literally forced people see what he
could see through the virtual reality
kits and then as anybody been in San San
Francisco during Salesforce tour
Dreamforce right you can't it's not that
much fun right try to get a hotel right
yeah yeah there's this hotel remember
it's right across the street from me
it's usually like $99 you wouldn't even
go in there and it's like 750 bucks a
night during Dreamforce
and they have such capacity they brought
in a cruise ship and parked it off the
Embarcadero right and again it was this
feeling of where another group think
when you see a hundred and fifty
thousand people come in to Dreamforce to
listen to Marc Benioff and the entire
ecosystem speak about the future of
cloud that's the king and that's on
purpose so maybe yeah
again some of the thoughts we had around
this journey is if you're at a dream
force or if you're at a big conference
or if you see that news or you read
about that PR or maybe you're just
burning around in an uber maybe this
would give you a different lens on the
world might give you a different way to
look at your look at the world as it's
all these categories that are around us
or more importantly if you have that big
tech insight or if you have that big
market insight these are some tools that
you could use to apply to making sure
people understand what you see and then
the last thing is you know Al and I
would like to join it invite you to join
us on our category design journey if you
liked or interested to hear more about
anything that we just talked about
there's about two hundred and thirty
pages coming out on this and a book
that's being released on June 14th and
we'd love it if you grabbed it took a
read and send us an email let us know
what you think so with that now come on
up
oh yeah yeah just one thing
I showed you the three musketeers photo
with me Chris and Dave there's one other
musketeer his name's Kevin meanie
he's a Newsweek writer and actually
Kevin was the one who helped us write
this so on that point let's let's have
some questions I bet there's some
questions in this room so put your hand
up we'll try and get a mic to you and
we'll try and repeat the questions for
the folks who are looking from the web
do you know you are in a category do you
have to be the one who designs in in
order to win it or can there be a
category that's designed by someone else
and you come in and eat their lunch
right a lot of examples of both actually
we always a nation so I'm sorry the
question is if you're in a category do
you need be the person who designed it
to win it and our short answer is yes if
you're in existing category fighting for
market share market cap and you didn't
invent it you better ask yourself who
did somebody else created that category
but what actually happens a lot and I
don't know if you remember the earlier
days of social business when companies
like jive and Yammer were coming out
with pretty hot companies one went
public when we got acquired by Microsoft
for over a billion dollars they paved
the road for companies like slack in
Atlassian who are now taking all their
work and turning it into and probably
monetizing even a bigger category around
whatever it ends up being called
collaboration so there's a lot of steps
in the road this journey we talked about
but I think the most important takeaway
is if you didn't design it you should
ask yourself who did and then maybe
start to look at the bigger picture and
say is the problem we're solving the
full category or is it one piece of a
bigger problem so that's how we look at
it any other questions new categories
that you are seeing emerge right now
what are some of the new categories
seeing emerge right now there's
literally dozens of them we meet with
probably 40 or 50 companies each year
the one I think that's most topical and
we actually talked about this in one of
the other Stanford courses is this
question of what's the front office now
and it's an incredible battle that's
unfolding you've got Dropbox in one
particular case which is if you like the
file system you've got slack which is
the
the company that's redefining how we
work as a team collaboration Atlassian
is another one specifically targeting
the technology we think that the front
office is being redefined in front of us
right now and it's a giant it's a giant
battle that's happening and the some of
the players at Google with all of the G
Drive and the Google Docs Microsoft
obviously has three companies in that
space including Skype and and their
their file sharing system so that's one
that's a really hot one another one as a
sort of a super category is big data in
and of itself we showed you this slide
with big data for example there's about
40 categories in that sort of super
category that are unfolding right now
and the way that Big Data and certainly
the vertical applications of using big
data is another one another one we
talked about in a recent newsletter is
this machine learning and some of the
applications of machine learning and one
one company that we work with actually
Stanford students who graduated last
year company called clear or metal metal
and if I can say it as an American and
clear metal out sort of revolutionising
how shipping happens and shipping
containers and so that's a vertical
application of machine learning we've
got another company in the HR space
that's doing so the same thing but it's
you know as you see in all of these
charts there's just this you know
incredible explosion and what normally
happens in as we said in that category
in the model is it starts out with
product market fit a dozen companies
start to get into the fight and
ultimately the the category definition
and the things you expect from that
category to deliver become clear
somewhere in that sort of two to four
year range and then one of those
companies becomes that thought leader
and ultimately rides off with all the
money yes sir
you have some things happening you have
customers like that see would maybe
press releases to get known would you
from that lightning strike point of view
would you hold off on that until you had
liked them so the question was if you're
a young company and you're wanting to
communicate to the world through press
releases order else how does the
lightning strike model apply to that I
think Dave the master of that so when a
human said yeah I don't know if I'm the
master I I think the answer is a
in the earliest stages of a company
there's a lot of work to be done to give
what they call product market fit we've
probably all heard that before and
there's a lot of iterations a lot of a
lot of ideas a lot of problems that
we're testing use cases you're testing
with customers and as well as adopt
you're growing your company right that
company design happens a lot too and I
think it's very fair to let that take
its due course and operate and and learn
and not necessarily declare you have the
answer if you don't absolutely know you
have that problem pegged you know
exactly how your tech or our market
insight solves that problem because
sometimes if you go out a little too
early you might set the table for
somebody else but again you kind of go
back to that that balance on that
triangle that's why that triangle
matters so much so I don't know if
there's a magic rule at what time but
anytime you feel like you really have
seen the same use case come through and
the same problem being solved with your
technology it's pretty good indication
you probably have at least cornered a
thought on what to call that category
and what to name it and I just point to
the company clear metal as an example
you know these these three guys out of a
garage basically came up with this
machine learning algorithm to figure out
where to put shipping containers and so
that early and they're talking to in
that particular case in enterprise we
definitely helped them with category
design and bedded it into the product
and the company as it was evolving so
did it is absolutely something you
should be doing in the early days it
will inform how your press release
sounds ill inform what your website
looks like in their particular case we
coined a sort of a soft toss at the
category called predictive logistics
we're not quite sure if that's the right
name for it just yet but you know
they're out evangelizing that and if it
spins from there then we think they'll
get there yeah yes ma'am
what so the question was what kind of
category do we belong to and how do we
design it do you want to tell that story
day that's a great question it's right
there the category that we belong to and
we're designing as category design and
there's a longer story and it's a it
started for me 20 years ago because we
always looked at solving marketing at
the time problems differently through
point of views and lightning strikes but
it didn't really coalesce into the full
kind of discipline until the last
probably five years and that's where we
did all the research and we started
realizing all of our gut you know
operator instinct you know when we were
athletes on the field had a pattern it
was coming on a sad day it's like wow I
do the same thing and every company I've
ever worked for
not a good day is wow this is a play
that we don't see a lot of other
companies running and so there's a
pretty long story in there but a lot of
it came from our operator days and then
certainly the research and then the
three years it took us to get all that
out of our heads and into our blueprint
in our playbook got it got it codify and
locked up so I don't know what your hips
version of that is but that's mine it's
good there's other questions here yes
sir how did your relationship come to
this review creating US company and
being able to work together how did the
three of us meet and how did the company
come together it's a great story so I
was the CMO of a company called
Macromedia put your hands up if you've
heard Macromedia in the audience all
right and that's good well I was the CMO
at that company and Dave and Christopher
the two other founders of play bigger
were actually marketing consultants to
macro media at the time and that's how
we got to know each other and we created
this category called rich internet
applications it got co-opted by pretty
much every major company in the tech
space out there and we had a point of
view called experience matters that
great experiences a great business and
if you was a designer or a developer or
delivering a great experience it's going
to be a good thing for your customer so
that's how it sort of all started we all
went off in our own directions as you
know as always happens in business
and then I within sold Macromedia Adobe
Dave and Chris were doing something
inside mercury interactive day then span
Anton was the CMO somewhere net-net of
it as we came back together about five
actually over five years ago now and we
decided that there was a lot here that
we had you know we're not gotten the
intuition that needed to come out and we
had to put this what we now call
category design we did not call it
categories and back then into play and
we decided that we put a company
together called play bigger and
ultimately that's that's what we that's
how it all started